la question est lent et celle de la
responsabilité la question politique ce
matin ou même du côté d'ailleurs du
paris saint-germain enfin des
organisateurs ou de la ligue mais quand
même le préfet de police disant que
c'était imprévisible enfin il faudrait
peut-être qu'ils reprennent des études
de sociologie mais la façon dont ça a
été monté organisé ne pouvait qu'aboutir
à quelque chose de ce type là écoutez
bon les actes sont intolérables
inqualifiable et tout le monde les
condamnent aujourd'hui
bon alors bien sûr comme les événements
seront sont intervenus dans la nuit et
dès le lendemain matin tout le monde dit
on n'aurait pas dû le faire mais je n'ai
jamais entendu ou je n'ai pas entendu
hier des gens s'offusquent et/ou dire
qu'il n'allait pas retransmettre en
direct le rassemblement parce que il y
avait des risques de violences hier
matin quand saviez que c'était une idée
idiote d'installer une fête de ce type
autres sur le trocadéro et ça m'a étonné
mais honnêtement j'ai pas fait un
communiqué élus parisiens en disant faut
pas le faire bon voilà parce qu'on était
installé dans la victoire du psg dont ce
qui s'était passé dans les stades qui
était plutôt mieux géré que d'habitude
et on n'a pas anticipé la connexion
entre ce que l'on avait pu lors des
manifestations pour le mariage pour tous
et les zoos les hooligans qui gravitent
autour du psg donc là il ya eu la
conjonction des deux évidemment ils se
sont donné à coeur joie
est-ce qu'il faut justement on appeler à
la démission manuel valls ont coûté faut
pas ajouter à des agissements de crétin
un débat débile c'est pas le manuel
valls et pour ma question parce que
derrière eux derrière veuve votre
question il y à des interpellations qui
ont eu lieu hier
si je puis dire
deux demandant la démission de manuel
valls s'est pas responsables de la crise
les responsables auraient alors
finalement dont je pense que il ya eu un
gros raté dans le sens où on a on n'a
pas anticipé mais personne l'a fait je
n'ai pas entendu par exemple madame dati
ou monsieur goasguen interpellé le maire
de paris où le préfet en disant faut pas
le faire pourtant monsieur l'oise aisne
et maire du xvième arrondissement la
mairie est à deux pas un jet de pierre
j'allais dire de du trocadéro il aurait
pu lui aussi il dit faut pas être trop
klépierre pour vous comprendre qu'on
allait vers la catastrophe sous entendu
la veille donc bon il faut condamner
il faut réfléchir aux événements il faut
peut-être les traités à la racine
mais ceci étant dit évidemment personne
n'avait est-ce que vous allez gilles
vincent va enchaîner sur les affaires
politiques mais ce que vous allez
jusqu'à l'idée qu' il ya derrière tout
ça aussi une acceptation du paris
saint-germain tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
c'est à dire un paris saint-germain
qatar qui n'est plus le paris saint
germain avant et qui a pris justement
des mesures notamment contre les ultras
qui sont peut-être un peu vendu
trocadéro peu ce c'est possible je n'ai
pas d'éléments pour le pouvoir le juger
mais il me semble dans mes souvenirs que
le paris saint germain ne s'est jamais
illustré dans ce genre de situation par
le calme
dans les précédentes équipes il ya
toujours eu des éléments de violence qui
se sont toujours articulée autour du
stade